Traductor: Sebastian Betti
Revisor: Gisela Giardino
Villas.
La vida en un mundo aparte.
Madres solas remando
contra un mar de piedra.
Una cultura del padre ausente,
del padre preso,
del padre acribillado,
del padre presente
pero con la espalda disecada.
Los cascotes que inventan caminos
así el barro no te muerde los tobillos.
Esqueletos de autos
robados y prendidos fuego.
Charlas de vecinas a través del alambrado
mientras cuelgan la ropa en la soga.
La policía y sus cacerías
entre carcajadas espumantes.
Policías parientes de su objetivo.
El comedor y su pálida merienda
entre una pesadumbre coloreada.
Los que se van a trabajar con sus
bolsitos, sus bicis y sus ojos cansados.
Madres que lloran la muerte del hijo
chorro, en velorios propios y ajenos.
Los evangelistas y sus gritos de mentira.
Los perros persiguiendo a las motos.
El guiso salvador del mediodía.
El mismo guiso a la noche.
Lo que quede de ese guiso mañana.
El micro que recorre las cárceles
desbordado de familiares.
La cumbia poniéndole ritmo a la miseria.
El amanecer y los carros.
El amanecer y los que
todavía siguen de gira.
Muchos sueldos flacos
destinados a disfrazar la pobreza.
Maradonas que mató la policía,
que son obreros que derrochan su magia
pero en una canchita de barro
y llena de vidrios.
La avenida es una frontera
que divide a la villa del mundo.
Por eso los rezos ofrendan hasta con sangre
por el milagro de exiliarse hacia afuera.
Sinfonía de la lluvia
maltratando a las chapas.
Extranjeros de la clase media
que vienen a comprar droga
y que se van descalzos y llorando.
Velas derritiéndose
en los minisantuarios
con las fotos de los pibes que murieron.
Paredes que recuerdan sus hazañas.
Las esquinas sonrientes,
con los guachos y las pibas,
salpicando chispas cósmicas.
Niños que se convierten en padres.
Habitantes que se conocen todos.
Secretos que saben todos.
Engaños imposibles de ocultar.
Donde vive la clase sin clase.
La única dueña de todas las escobas.
Donde no llegan los premios
de la meritocracia.
Donde el horizonte
siempre tiene olor a celda.
Tiene olor a bala.
Tiene olor a trabajo precario.
Tiene olor a traje
de encargado de limpieza.
Es la villa. Es otro mundo.
Es vivir apartado.
(Aplausos)
Muchas gracias.
Max Goldenberg: César, ¿cuándo, cómo
y para qué escribiste este poema?
César González: Bueno, este poema fue
escrito hace casi 10 años, más o menos.
Yo tenía 19 en ese entonces.
Estaba preso en el penal de Marcos Paz.
Estuve cinco años preso.
Fue una forma de salir a dar una vuelta
por mi barrio sin tener que moverme,
porque tampoco podía, ¿no?
Fue una forma de recrear la experiencia
a partir del recuerdo,
con la imaginación.
Fue dar esa vuelta por el barrio,
de forma imaginaria,
pero no simplemente dar una vuelta
por el barrio y describir
--no me interesaba simplemente describir
sino agregarle a esa descripción un filtro,
que es el filtro de mi concepción
de cómo es vivir en la villa--
Para mucha gente
no se vive como la vivo yo,
con las palabras que le pongo yo
a la vida en la villa,
así que fueron filtros filosóficos,
políticos, ideológicos
de cosas que pasan en la villa que
son injustas, que no deberían pasar.
Es decir, no romantizar la vida
en la villa, pero también, bueno,
rescatar toda la belleza que surge
en medio de tanta muerte, ¿no?
Max Goldenberg: César González, señores.
(Aplausos)
César González: Muchas gracias.